bonjour bonjour à vous tous avouent
qu'ils nous écouter et qui nous
regardaient également en ligne sur le
web vous êtes sur martinique la première
et d'en face à la première édition
spéciale autour des 50 ans des
événements de mai 1968 en france et plus
largement sur cette période de la fin
des années 60
plutôt agitée dans le monde entier mais
mais en martinique que s'est il passé à
cette période
l'agitation du moment avait-elle aussi
gagné notre île peut-être même le
département et à l'époque uniquement
département tout comme la guadeloupe et
la guyane d'ailleurs ce département de
la martinique avait t-il connu sa propre
révolte peu auparavant à la fin des
années 50 au début des années 60
nous envisagerons toutes ces questions
avec nos invités et en outre je le
précise avec l'une de nos
interlocutrices vous écouterez donc le
témoignage d'une martiniquaise ayant
participé à mai 68 à paris d'ailleurs je
commence par la présente et elle madame
danielle mia bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
effectivement vous nous confirmez donc
que vous étiez ah oui à paris au moment
de mai 68 et d'ailleurs j'ai passé mon
diplôme d'infirmière
cette année là et en était assez ennuyé
parce qu'on savait pas trop s'il allait
avoir lieu
bon voilà autre invité yvette haybions
bonjour un jeu toujours militante
féministe vous alors tout à l'heure vous
allez nous préciser un peu plus en
détail ce que vous faisiez où vous étiez
à cette période ne vous êtes arrivée en
martinique en scène l'année 1968 voilà
andré lucrèce sociologue écrivain
bonjour bonjour merci d'être là une voix
bien connue sur l'antenne de martinique
la première voilà ainsi d'invitation et
l'historien et écrivain armonico là
bonjour harmonieux la bonjour bain
c'est une coupe au moins en tant que
comme public
si j'ai tilté line période floue je peux
dire c'est une période chaude
donc voilà on fera appel à vos mémoires
à chacun d'entre vous merci pour cet
exercice est d'abord j'ai envie de vous
demander à chacun d'entre vous alors
madame sy on terminera avec vous parce
que vous nous commencerons à nous donner
votre témoignage
mais en mai 68 où étiez vous que faisiez
vous et suivez vous l'actualité de la
crise sociale et politique majeure
d'alors en france d'abord vous il était
bien mais moi j'étais en algérie et en
tant que militante politique
donc nous avons suivi ça sur europe 1
d'abord très surpris parce qu'on était
pris dans d'autres autres combats il y
avait eu la guerre des six-jours nos
avants n'était pas tellement ça nous a
surpris et on suivait toutes les nuits
avec europe ont collé à nos oreilles on
se demander comment une révolte
étudiante comme ça et très vite j'ai eu
le relais quand même j'avais une soeur
étudiante à toulouse qui me relate m est
jamais l'impression de deux choses
différentes à toulouse et est ce que
j'entendais sur paris savait pas les
mêmes succès oui oui elle attend y avait
une grève générale dans toute la france
à mais les les événements les émeutes
les manifestations étaient surtout à
paris et les écoute qu'on avait c'était
surtout avec les étudiants si 71 alors
vous dites on écoutait europe 1 il faut
préciser sans trop entrer dans votre vie
privée que c'est là vous avez connu
votre mari un martiniquais donc roger et
lyon vous étiez en algérie à ce moment
là et vous être en très peu de temps
après en octobre à la fin des années 60
en août en août avec votre
marie des machines élèves et vous êtes
devenu une martiniquaise adoption voilà
un défi puisque vous avez longtemps
milité à lui fm vous avez même été
présidente de l'union des femmes de la
martinique peu de temps après 68
d'ailleurs non seulement très bien
armand nicolas en mai 1968 où étiez-vous
que faisiez-vous mais j'étais bien en
martinique et un martiniquais parce que
les événements de 68
bien sûr on les a suivis mais on les a
suivis
je lirai d'assez jouer et parce qu'une
gestion ont embarqué martiniquaise qui
était pas mal secoué et on déterre
encore dans dans la suite des événements
de les 159 des conséquences et des
changements qui se sont produits à ce
moment de l'annoncé et il est assez
important et notamment aux événements
politiques sociales c'est la conséquence
était j'étais dans un combat qui s'était
accentuée depuis il
on va on va y revenir et vous étiez à ce
moment-là professeur c'est ça vous étiez
d'enseignants provenant non non non je
n'étais plus professeurs puisque vous
aviez été j'avais tirez-vous révoqué en
1961 parce que j'avais refusé l'exil
qu'on voulait qu'on voulait m'imposer
véreux outre-atlantique donc et donc
j'ai complètement
j'étais d'ailleurs devenu secrétaire
général du parti communiste du nickel et
j'avais donc cette responsabilité
principale qui me qui me collait sur mon
pays et souge l'environnement politique
le four à pizza est d'ailleurs voilà
andré lucrèce
vous êtes un peu plus jeune que l'on les
autres invités en en mai 68 où étiez
vous que faisiez vous écoutez j'étais
étudiant oui j'étais étudiant et parce
que j'ai fait mes études il était à
bordeaux ce que j'ai fait mes études
d'abord à bordeaux ensuite avec 100
province et puis j'ai terminé à paris
pour la ma thèse de doctorat et donc à
ce moment là j'étais à bordeaux je crois
puisque je crois d'ailleurs que j'étais
en licence
je terminais ma licence de sociologie et
pour moi justement mai 68 c'était une
opportunité sociologique est absolument
extraordinaire
pourquoi parce que tout simplement on
avait là sous mes yeux une société entre
française en train de se transformer et
surtout on avait sous les yeux un grand
mouvement émancipateur cessa mai 68
mai 68 c'est un mouvement émancipateur
c'est une révolte qui qui refusait en
fait une société à la fois triste et et
j'ai envie de dire très très prosaïque
parce qu'ils ont vu oui ce que vous êtes
parce que en fait si vous voulez cette
révolte
c'était à la fois une révolte contre à
la force contre eux le
le libéralisme à tout crin
d'une part et puis d'autre part
également cette société consumériste
pour nous préparer c'est d'ailleurs à ce
moment là que les georges perec tu écris
un livre qui s'appelle les choses les
choses c'est à dire en quelque sorte la
symphonie de la marchandise qui
d'ailleurs a continué par la suite et
qui a été aujourd'hui m ce que je
voudrais souligner c'est mai 68 est un
mouvement émancipateur contre une
société répressive d'abord socialement
répressif ensuite je dirais policiers
ans dépressif et troisièmement
sexuellement dépressive
donc je rappelle par exemple que à cette
époque où l'avortement était et est donc
condamnable et juste par exemple
comme j'étais à bordeaux donc les
villages étudiants s'appelait donc juste
mauvais l'église centre étudiant de donc
d'hébergement et ça paie des villages et
par exemple et les garçons n'avaient pas
le droit d'aller au village des filles
n'est pas de mixité est alors sur tout
le champ laïcité pouvait se faire un
saut sévère c'est à dire que les filles
pouvaient élytre il en évidence des
garçons mais merci non et donc vous
voyez un petit peu que c'était une
société qui était le mot c'est pour ça
que le mosquée roisin lui convient tout
ça évidemment après mai 68 a sauté à
sauter donc il y avait une sorte d'ordre
moral aussi très très prégnant quoi en
quelque sorte mais dites moi avant d'en
venir à daniel mia vous l'étudiant que
vous étiez à bordeaux à ce moment là
vous aviez quel âge donc en 68 si c'est
pas gênant
ce que si j'avais une vingtaine d'années
vous avez pris part au mouvement vous
vous intéressiez c'était quelque chose
vous étiez dedans dans ce bouillonnement
écouter justement jeu en venant à
l'émission j'étais en train de réfléchir
pour savoir si j'étais déjà président de
la jem qui est l association générale
des étudiants martinique est très
marquée très âgées
ils étaient engagés collectivement alors
bien entendu nous étions évidemment dans
le mouvement pour les raisons que j'ai
dit d'ailleurs tout à l'heure c'était un
mouvement à la fois étudiants et
ouvriers et n'oubliez pas qu'à bordeaux
et on s'était lié à eux aussi il y avait
aussi des martinique est ouvrier
notamment sur les quais nous nous
rencontrions donc ces ouvriers
martiniquais dont pour dire que nous ne
pouvions que nous engager et je vais je
vais ajouter une dernière chose c'est
que cette conscience de l'engagement et
avait déjà été préparée par les
événements que vous avez évoqué c'est à
dire décembre 59 1961
n'oubliez pas et où il y eu le discours
de glaciation bien sûr une fois ton on
va advenir d'ouvriers et puis aussi en
1962 la fameuse affaire des tricots qui
a ou cave qui a occasionné une émeute de
l'incroyable à fort de france
donc nous étions déjà si vous voulez al
oqla à ce moment là j'étais nice et 1,9
attendus dans ces années là et nous
étions déjà un petit peu préparés à
cette conscientisation j'avoue que je
connais presque pas du tout la sphère
des tricots mai juin que vous avez nous
en donner qu'un film en quelques mots et
ainsi que monsieur nicolas alors on en
vient à vous daniel miam adhamiyah donc
vous vous n'étiez pas étudiant vous
étiez à paris en mai 68 et des
étudiantes mais vous appréciez donc à
passer le concours
non mais pas assez développé
les études du raid étudiant temps quel
que soit le terme aux personnes qui
étudient prête à aider qu'ils soient et
cabin fever le nomme étudiants
maintenant alors c'était assez archaïque
parce que sans hospitalier universitaire
c'est devenu sentence plus ta vie
universitaire n'était pas à l'époque
mais est ce que vous vous étiez parti
par le guildo c'est ça c'est ça oui oui
c'est ça mais le bureau des migrations
de voilà comment d'autres mais voilà
donc j'ai fait mes études à nantes
je voulais être monitrice éducatrice
j'ai travaillé au foyer du lazaret avant
de partir j'avais eu ce concours et où
je ne voulais pas rester parce que on
changeait de directrice la directrice
qu'on aura eu faisait ses études elle
revenait en tant que cadre non premiers
pas ce mot là avant on disait
surveillante et c'était une dame
convenait on avait une blouse de travail
et au lazaret et là elle allait tout
réformer et peut-être que je n'étais pas
très j'ai pas le caractère passif et
donc ça ça me dérange et je préférerais
qu'on travaille en blouse et là tout
allait changer
et donc j'ai dit non on va partir je
savais que notre vie on s'entendait bien
gênant nous allons partir nous a fait
miroiter que si on revenait après les
l'année on en est un poste et tous nous
on a voulu partir pour pouvoir autre
chose est ce que je ne regrette pas
d'abord alors vous avez donc participé à
windows il est aux manifestations dans
des rues à part oui oui une fois d'aller
à la manifestation où il était au
boulevard du temple qu'on abaisse ronde
et oui je me souviens qu'on est vraiment
resté très longtemps je connaissais
assez bien ce quartier monnaie c'est
très longtemps sur place
quand on fait un défilé mais c'était par
rapport aux conditions de travail qu'on
avait nous parce qu'il n'y avait pas eu
au centre hospitalier sainte-anne et
nettoie les maladies mentales
il n'y avait pas de classe il n'y avait
pas des aides soignants il n'y avait pas
deux
de gens qu'on appelait les femmes de
service maps api trop c'était des des
diplômes et des élèves
et après vous êtes diplômé vous reprenez
la succession faisait la vaisselle on
allait chercher le linge alors on avait
un chariot chariot comme j'ai pas encore
retrouve dans l'agriculture là on allait
avec le chariot et puis vous l'avez
malade qu'il reste avec nous c'était
parce qu'ils avaient un pécule donc on
nous on était vraiment considéré comme
un peu comme une servante parce qu'on
appelle encore le bonnet maintenant il
ya plus ça c'était vraiment on prenait
pas avec les patients parce que si on
parle avec passion c'est qu'on fait
derrière c'est bien longtemps après
qu'on a compris qu'il fallait justement
le dialogue avec avec les patients donc
à cause de ces conditions de travail
c'était huit heures et c'était tout le
temps est alors passé aussi la
serpillière on allait chercher on
connaît pas ça ici
le savon noir ont touché ça en liquide
douala et on allait tous chercher
l'infirmière allaient tous chercher
c'était elle et comme on était élève à
11 octobre vous étiez un peu presque
corvéable à avoir les infos raid comme
ça voilà et donc c'est contre ces
conditions de travail sont les atouts
des laitiers à ce moment là avec des
syndicats plutôt dans les cortèges
syndicaux
non non non non non ma question et puis
là je vais ensuite interrogé on va
revenir à à la martinique a assuré me
caisse de l'époque mais comme on a ce
témoignage direct est-ce que vous
côtoyez à ce moment là dans cette
manifestation mais plus largement au
moment de ces événements est ce que il y
avait beaucoup d'antillais qui étaient
dans les rues qui s'intéressait à ça
qu'ils voulaient aller participer aussi
qu'ils soient ouvriers ou étudiants ou
tout à fait autre chose aussi parce que
j'appartiens il y avait des martiniquais
aussi un ace que ce qu'il y avait un des
groupes
est-ce que vous ne s'était passé le
noyau ce qu'ali faisait il y avait des
syndicats qui se réunissaient mais je ne
suis pas allé il y avait deux doit aller
au piquet de grève
on appelait ça le piquet de grève
d'accord tu étais devant l'enceinte du
bâtiment et on pouvait y aller sur son
au travail armand nicolas quelques
comment vous aviez connaissance de ce
qui se passait à ce moment là
en france en france hexagonale je vais
dire alors parce que évidemment il n'y
avait pas d'envoyer l'information
d'aujourd'hui y avait des journaux et la
radio voilà n'était pas encore lancée
mais 64 est bon en suivait quand même ce
qui se passait là bas
à travers eux à travers la presse à
travers la radio et j'ai tapé pour
l'essentiel avec quelques parents
étaient des enfants lavables voilà des
relations ces digues est le même les
échanges téléphoniques n'étaient pas si
fréquent que ça non plus
en 68 oui un petit peu quand même mais
bon tu pourrais jamais faire mais bon
c'est comme ça qu'on était un type
informé mais en fait
l'amant cynique je dirais que là vous la
motivation de 68 était différente de
celle des forces populaires qui se sont
exprimés sous nouvelle grille lenteur en
1900 les les
cette période de 66 et la martinique
elle est elle n'est pas un prolongement
ou nappes et 10 de 68
c'est une évolution qu'on à l'évolution
julie rey 2
historique d'un pays d'un peuple elle la
période de 1900 1950 à 1960
c'est une période très très mouvementée
et très riche historiquement et elle se
situe dans la foulée de liaison 59 qui a
été le grand le grand gibier est le
grand événement de
de ceux travaillant dans l'après-guerre
et à partir duquel il a eu justement la
dizaine d'années qui suit a été une
période de millions sur tous les plans
sélectionnant actionnement dans ce
schéma oui et je suis humain je résume
un peu je pense que c'est l'indicateur
principal de cette période ça a été
après la période de la terreur politique
ouais on la voit la voix l'a un peu
oublié mais lorsqu'au lorsqu'on comprend
lorsqu'on prend elle file des différents
événements qui se sont produits durant
cette période c'est vraiment dans
l'histoire de la martinique ce
d'ailleurs dans toute l'histoire du pcc
période de la terreur politique
alors on va on va on va développer un
petit peu mais andré lucrèce c'est vrai
on a l'impression à tort ou à raison que
mai 68 a été le l'objet alors pas d'une
totale indifférence ici en martinique
à ce moment là mais quand même d'une
certaine distance et pas seulement
géographique mais ça ne veut pas dire
pour autant que la société était
léthargique quoique le caler quelle
somme n'est complètement c'est que les
aspirations n'étaient pas les mêmes à ce
moment là c'est ça il y avait un
décalage entre la france hexagonale et
messi et je disais la martinique qui
sort de la du statut de colonie mais qui
n'est pas encore région qui n'est que
département qui bon voila quand on a
l'impression que dans un entre deux qua
non mais c'est à dire que les
problématiques ne sont pas les mêmes
comme je le disais tout à l'heure ce que
c'était une crise sociologique latin en
france et c'était c'était finalement un
au revoir à une société donc eux
vous avez dit tout à l'heure sclérosé et
en fait les individus donc qu'ils
étaient des acteurs voulait se tourner
vers un monde mais un monde absolument
radicalement différent de ce qu'on avait
connu ce qu'ils avaient connue en france
bon et donc c'est ça me 68
en revanche à la martinique on est dans
une autre problématique laquelle mais
d'abord ce qui est annoncé par les trois
événements que j'ai cités tout à l'heure
c'est à dire des 159 1960 et 1962 nous
sommes là si vous voulez dans une
problématique de deux de résistance à
une oppression coloniale
il faut dire les mots tels qu'ils sont
et vous me posiez la question à propos
des de l'affairé des tricots oui ben
c'est précisément ça va vous montrer que
nous sommes justement dans une logique
coloniale il se trouve que l'algérie
consomme et dépendances 1961 quasiment
sûr puisque c'est 60 de fans on meurt
donc à en décembre 261 et donc n'a pas
eu le temps de voir c'était les bardes
et nous sommes 1,62 donc l'algérie pour
son indépendance
mais les combats ont déjà commencé
depuis très longtemps en algérie
la guerre fait rage de libération
nationale fait rage et qu'est ce qui se
passe c'est que les pieds noirs qui sont
algérie commencent à chercher à aller
ailleurs des points de chute des points
de chute après l'un des meneurs
cependant même les ailleurs mais oui
parce que nous sommes en pleine guerre
colonial en algérie et donc nous
recevons ici des pieds-noirs et
d'affaires des tricots et une affaire
très simple c'est que un certain nombre
de jeunes qui est noir utilisait un
t-shirt sur lequel il y avait une rose
des vents c'était et ils interdisaient
aux jeunes martiniquais de porter ces
tricots et non bien entendu de la part
de ces jeunes martiniquais
c'était des dégâts mecque des jeunes
gens qui étaient évidemment lycée
schoelcher ces jeunes qui est noir et
bien entendu bon les connaisseurs me
connaissez leurs noms etc et donc il ya
eu une bagarre parce que tout simplement
bien les martiniquais ont décidé où
précisément les jeunes martiniquais ont
décidé de porter ces tricots et ça s'est
terminé par des émeutes ou là la police
est intervenue
c'était assez significatif si vous
voulez de l'atmosphère qui régnait était
à 7
à cette époque c'est pour ça que je dis
que c'est une problématique du mois
cologna une existence si vous voulez une
oppression que comme disait avant tout à
l'heure nous subite que nous subissions
et et qui était en fait si vous voulez
des 159 en est donc la manifestation
avec une forte dépression et c'est ce
qu'ils disent est une régression qu'on
n'avait jamais connu en tout cas sous
cette forme et en particulier n'oublions
pas ça une aubaine urbaine parce que
jusqu alors les répressions était contre
les ouvriers agricoles n'est ce pas on
va citer le françois et puis tout ce qui
a suivi après mais ces contretemps et
williams en finale parce que j'aurais pu
y échapper
et comme il est il évoque un événement
qui est parfaitement caractérisés devant
lui et qui est typique à cette affaire
dite qui courent on a eu deux côtés donc
une somme d'abord la scission la rupture
entre les nantis et ces jeunes
gens qui se loue qui quittait trajet
pense que les murphy rémy des
tricots identique rouler ou qu'il
ressemblait beaucoup voient assure de
ces messieurs
cc c'est le sac là c'est parti bon dans
la sphère du tricot il ya eu des
manifestations très forte des 18 tubes
le lycéen dans l'ue ou le hall de france
arrêtée mais la répression n'est pas
tombé tel - lou les les acteurs des
mouvements mais par d'autres et en
particulier par nous non nous
aujourd'hui communiqué
oui hé hé hé mois grâce également
puisque j'étais secrétaire général j'ai
été poursuivi dans la sphère des tricots
on a pensé que j'avais inspiré selon la
cgt j'ai été poursuivi puis condamné à
une amende que ces terrains parce que en
matière de frapper le parti communisme
ans michael ne trouve un prétexte pour
le frapper alors que bon j'avais été
comme tout le monde spectateurs dans les
rues et boulevards les choses se passer
mais ça aurait suffi pour qu'en mai et
que épinglé simplement comme secrétaire
général est poursuivi uniquement est
condamné et qu'on d'aller j'étais donc
ça n'était d'ailleurs qu'un aspect des
de la répression un jeu j'ai un tableau
assez chargé le conte de la nation
tout n'a plus aucun droit du seul fait
que si vous étiez
réponse grâce pour cette île
il a souligné une flotte importante à la
pensée unique
à cette époque là on a saisi le journal
publie six jeunes la plupart qui 14
points tout à fait eh bien merci
il va très bien que quand vous arrivez
donc enfin 68 en martinique est ce que
vous réalisez tout de suite est ce que
vous prenez le pouls de cette société
effectivement et que vous rendez compte
que c'est une société qui est encore à
ce moment là vraiment en pleine
évolution d'un point de vue de cet exode
rural vers fort-de-france et sa
périphérie des mouvements sociaux
voilà qui émerge ici ou là par de
manière sporadique quoirin par des
périodes mais voilà et puis une jeunesse
surtout une jeunesse en nombre il ya
beaucoup de jeunes à ce moment là qu'on
fait partir parce que c'est une jeunesse
aussi martiniquaise qui en proie à
l'incertitude de l'avenir quoi on peut
dire ça comme ça est ce que vous vous
ressentez ça tout de suite de manière
forte
quand je suis arrivé en algérie j'ai
atterrir aux terres sainville
ahmadinejad en martinique oui en
martinique allait faire sa vie louis et
aux terres sainville et comme j'étais
aux jeunesses communistes j'ai de suite
adhéré au parti à bois donc vous avez
côtoyé avant nicolas le solage fitte
duval et nous c'est ce que je peux dire
c'est ce que ça a apporté aux femmes
parce que mai 68 ça a été quand même
essentiellement la mixité la mixité qui
n'existait pas avant
mais toujours école de filles école de
garçons aussi là c'était une femme
n'allait pas tout seul dans boule dans
un café encore moi aller au cinéma seul
c'était un truc impensable donc moi j'ai
surtout vécu ça dans le ce que ça a
apporté aux femmes j'avais j'ai eu 2
enfants parce que je suis arrivé quinze
jours avant la messe
c'est mon deuxième enfant deux enfants
non je vous assure que me suis battu
pour la contraception et l'avortement
et ça a été ce combat là qu'on a mené de
suite après 60 s que vous expliquer ce
qu'il avait de quoi faire il y avait du
pain sur la planche en la matière il y
avait du pain sur la planche à la
matière alors là j'ai pris avec yvette
m'envoie et solange ont il y avait par
exemple été des mois c'était valable
pour toute la france
andré lucrèce l'a rappelé mais c'était
plus marquée encore si c'est ce que
voulait dire c'était plus un peu plus
malgré la bonne raison qu'il y avait on
n'avait pas l'égalité je vais vous dire
une chose justement que j'étais enceinte
en algérie j'avais des prestations que
je n'ai pas eu en martinique pour mon
second front donc c'est pour vous dire
la différence était beaucoup plus
marquée et et aussi les taux de
mortalité infantile était beaucoup plus
élevé fall la situation était beaucoup
plus prégnante ici de toute manière quel
que soit le pays c'était des combats
qu'il fallait mener à l'est que ça s'est
déclenchée parce que quand même mai 68
c'est parti avec les étudiants de la
sorbonne et c'était dans beaucoup de
pays c'est selon l'originalité en france
c'est que le mouvement ouvrier à
rejoindre les étudiants sans saveur ces
salles originalité mais au départ
c'était vraiment et je les échos que
j'avais de ma soeur à toulouse c'était
vraiment le retour à la nature des
jeunes qui rêvait de 2
debaire de devenir berger d'avoir des
bergeries c'est casse était l'heureux et
se sont devenus des babas cool et je les
rencontre encore sont toujours mises en
garde ils ont repris leurs études
quand même pas la même mais c'était ça a
pris ce 1068 ça s'est transformé plus
tôt en juin 68 quand c'est là que ça et
et l'originalité du 2d 68 des événements
de 68 pour moi gagner mia je disais que
oui à ce moment là effectivement il y
avait une jeunesse martiniquaise qui
avait une certaine un certain certitude
à l'avenir l'ingénieur c'est vrai oui
vous en témoigner vous même vous vous
êtes parti de vous même vous aviez envie
ou c'est plutôt contraintes que parce
que vous saviez qui s'ils n'avaient pas
parfois la voix la manche à liège
touchée à l'époque 3700 350 francs soit
1 35 franc quoi c'était si tu salaires
qui étaient quittés bons pour une
célibataire tout ça et j'en donnais
aussi à mes parents mais j'ai compris
que l'avenir ne jouait pas eu d'avenir
ici donc je nous sommes partis avec ma
copine c'est toute une génération
effectué mais il a dû être concernés
andré du crin cette année je voulais
donc pas les ai juste que vous avez fait
les tee shirts mais à nantes c'était là
que je vous ai dit que je vends les
études et bien les filles venaient
d'algérie
elle avait un petit calendrier il y
avait deux pieds noirs de pied les pieds
devant
pour illustrer oui andré lucrèce
non ce que je voulais souligner nous
avez vous avez raison de dire que la
situation était extrêmement difficile
pour la jeunesse parce que évidemment ne
faut pas oublier que nous sommes là dans
la période où des usines ferment les
unes après les autres
donc il y a donc non seulement de
travailleurs sont au chômage mais il n'y
a pas de perspective dans le milieu
rural en tout cas de travail et à la vie
finalement
et il y as peut-être quelques
possibilités ce qui fait que vous avez
un double mouvement
un mouvement qui quitte le l'espace
rural pour venir vers espaces urbains et
bien entendu fort de france et c'est à
ce moment là d'ailleurs que se
construisent ce qu'on appelait la
ceinture populaire de fort de france
c'est-à-dire trinel tu hexagone et
terrain on se mettait et volga on se
mettait donc dans dans des espaces
qu'ils pouvaient être exploités où on
pouvait monter une habitation
et puis mes et puis toute la deuxième
chose c'est que il faut pas donc
difficulté pour les jeunes mais en même
temps il faut pas non plus négliger la
crête du gouvernement mérite parce que
60 59 1961 1962
le gouvernement doit payer en plus il
voit que ce sont les jeunes il tape
effectivement sur armand mais vous avez
il faut pas oublier loge m donc ils
t'assure armand parce que rarement doc
est effectivement mais c'est le symbole
et le cerveau de cette résistance le
secrétaire de parti communiste pendant
très très longtemps et mais en même
temps donc il ya cette crypte d'une
jeunesse qui qui est dans la rue qui il
ya des émeutes etc
et n'oubliez pas qu'en décembre 59 sont
des jeunes qui meurent ce sont des
jeunes qui demain ils se disent mais il
ya une opportunité là elle se dit et le
costume tout de suite ce qu'on peut
appeler une déportation le début me
donne
c'est ce que j'allais sagesse que j'ai
c'est une conséquence 259 on a décidé de
le développer des migrations pour se
débarrasser du sud c'est éléments qui
commençait à s'agiter sagittaire et en
menacer le système est bien on se couche
jamais
mais au fond donc on va présenter sa
commune possibilité donc pour les poules
et les jeunes martiniquais de pouvoir
aller en france et que c'était à et donc
trouver du travail mais en même temps en
réalité ils veulent s'en débarrasser
parce que n'oublions pas non plus que le
taux de fécondité à l'époque n'a rien à
voir avec aujourd'hui rien à voir c'est
un taux de fécondité extrêmement élevé
donc on a une jeunesse pléthorique
alors qu'aujourd'hui vous avez vu dans
quel état c'est plutôt on arrive déjà un
petit peu la dernière partie de notre
émission je voudrais qu'on parle aussi
de ajustement du monde politique à ce
moment là la décennie 60
c'est une classe politique alors hormis
le parti communiste martiniquais j'ai
envie d'être là qui joue plutôt la carte
de l'apaisement y compris le ppm d'aimé
césaire alors baril et maire de
fort-de-france députés mais c'est plutôt
la droite
comment dirais-je golo pompidolienne qui
qui domine un peu les débats les
affaires peut-être ici quand même en
remuant martinique dominé qui dominent
des affaires qui manie le chaud et le
froid alors il ya de la répression c'est
vrai des mouvements même temps lâche
c'est vrai au compte-gouttes quelques
mesures sociales quand même pour apaiser
ses mots ces mouvements de fièvre quoi
et puis et puis voilà quoi
et puis quand même commence à poindre à
la fin des années 60
peut-être quand même alors ça a commencé
effectivement d'elle et la fin des
années 50 un effectivement avec le jeune
tout simplement on voit poindre des
revendications
peut-être pas encore d'autonomie si je
crois que le parti communiste-parti
nickel a déjà je m'endors depuis 1960 au
moins de décentralisation il ya aussi
cette inspiration dans la classe
politique martiniquais le parti commu
même si la page ou encore la simulation
alors qu'ils corrigent martiniquais a
lancé le symbole d'autonomie et à
développer l'idée que l'autonomie c'est
2 c'est un moyen de sortir de l'ornière
où des pâtes et départementaliste com
et indiqué hé bien le parti communiste
martiniquais a décidé en 1960 de
revendiquer un statut d'autonomie
l'employant en employant le terme terre
n'avaient clairement autonomie et ce
n'est pas par hasard que la répression
s'est abattue sur le parti communiste du
fait qu' il mettait en cause le système
colonial de manière beaucoup plus forte
qu avec la départementalisation
l'assimilation et c est en fait j'ai où
j'ai eu ou si simplement doux pour un
truc en mieux après des hommes 6,9 après
les cinq acteurs
le gouvernement s'est engagé dans une
politique à deux visages visage
la carotte et un autre visage le bâton
le bâton il tombait fort le nom à ce
moment là ben comme on a revendiqué sa
plus kim est petit mais tf qui mettait
en cause le système colonial
le gouvernement a dit attention ça
devient sérieux c'est la faute de cuba
et caetera et caetera et les horizons
francs ils ont frappé et on m'a en main
et je suis omar évoqué en 61 mais un
soir un homme avait déjà passé devant le
tribunal pour atteinte à l'intégrité du
territoire alors je reviens je reviens
est ce que est ce que le personnel
politique est ce que des politiques est
ce que au sein par exemple du parti
communiste martiniquais est ce que dans
la presse martiniquaise de de cette
période
est ce que on évoquait ce qu'on parlait
ce qu'on faisait référence à ce qui se
passait en france à ce moment là oui
mais débattre
avions des fréquentations localement
unique elle est prioritaire et laurie
terre prioritaire il y avait non
seulement ces affaires bon j'ai été
condamné avec le secrétaire général du
parti communiste de l'époque pour le
changement statut pour avoir revendiqué
ferme et athus s'était pas encore s'ils
n'étaient pas encore possible et c'est
devenu possible
heureusement grâce aux jeux livrés aux
sacrifices des jeunes de l'ojam parce
que le leu le crime le procès qui a été
fait j'ai terminé par un jugement qui
est considère que la revendication de
nouveau ni quelle autonomie barish
jaaksi cadre strict chaque citoyen a le
droit de le proposer des changements
pour le l'institution et à ce moment là
d'ailleurs
et quand je me mets né et a demandé est
proposée l'indépendance qui allait
au-delà alors 70 71 72 peut-être cru que
j'étais décidé j'attends quartier des
raguenets reims et adela d'homère et
atteindre le top secret il ya eu il y
avait déjà
deux groupes indépendantistes qui
existaient way est effectivement donc et
puis a eu ensuite l'apparition nîmes
mais il ya eu effectivement certain
nombre de groupes indépendantistes qui
sont et des journaux d'ailleurs inquiété
bien entendu en 68 oui alors non un peu
allemand c'est certes un petit peu
disons oui c'est dans la foulée quoi
après c'est dans ce période de l'année
sur des années 60 depuis le début des
années 60 il y avait des groupes
indépendantistes notamment dans l'école
ou dans les campagnes où ben yeoh dans
les lycées au lycée nos policiers que sa
va faire long terme et publié des petits
voilà c'est très bien que c'est le seul
ogm qui a été comme ça
bani yas soit intervenir ah oui voilà
pourquoi je dis que mai 68 a apporté du
plus à la population parce que avant on
travaillait il fallait faire sept jours
on travaillait six jours pour avoir un
jour de repos et après comment on a pu
arriver à donner davantage de repos et
ce qui m'arrivait souvent c'est comme
j'étais la plus jeune entrez dans le
service alors tous comme j'avais déjà
dit tout à l'heure
tout ce que les autres ne voulaient pas
faire eh bien ça tombait sûrement
j'étais la dernière entrée
j'avais déjà fait ma journée et un
infirmier qui n'était pas venue est bien
la plus jeune c'était elle qui doublait
qu'il faisait une journée double et
savaient pas du côlon demain ah oui il
ya quand même beaucoup de 10 et de
l'exploitation de réactualisation oui
oui venir habiter faiblesse change fait
quoi en fait le lait les fluence le 68
qui a un change qui avait conduit en
france à des changements importants
quand même
eh bien ils ils se sont répercutées chez
idc
ces nouvelles dispositions sur la
transition pour soi
ok en martinique
bon disons que nous avons bénéficié des
bénéfices qu'ils feraient en 1901 1968
mais elle met la politique qui a été
suivie si ces réalités de la politique
propre propre à une situation bleus pays
colonial face à ce puissant très bien
avant avant d'en venir justement à
l'évolution des moeurs qui ont suivi
aussi dans la société martiniquaise
après cette période de mai 68 un petit
peu avant un petit peu après et c'est
surtout le sociologue et madame et bien
que j'avais interrogé là-dessus armonico
la dernier mot quand même à ce moment là
parce que c'est vrai il y avait grève
générale en france il y avait grève
générale c'est dans les transports
surtout dans les tags aux difficultés
ici est ce que le mot d'ordre de grève
générale a été non n'a pas spécialement
spécialement alors quand j'ai entendu
certains le dire bah oui c'est parce
qu'à l'époque il y avait une classe
ouvrière en martinique qui était plutôt
majoritairement hostile à une violence
généralisée
on faisait des grèves des grèves dures
des grèves qui étaient réprimées c'est
vrai mais il n'y avait pas une classe
ouvrière particulièrement violente dans
les années 60 en faire don qui bravaient
la cdg n'est pas ce que je voyais la
généralisation de surprises y est il ya
une tradition la tradition notamment
dans la culture de fraises à chaque mot
là-dessus presque chaque année au moment
de la discussion du salaire m à voile à
l'école il ya venait des négociations
qui ne marche jamais et c'était très
sage
à ce moment là c'était très tendu il y
avait des grèves générales d'ouvriers
agricoles d'accord quand même alors vous
me rendrez la martinique à cette époque
n'est pas un pays industrialisé comme la
france les grèves par exemple cherono
emmené 68 c'était des choses absolument
extraordinaire les ouvriers doisneau et
d'aider des leaders si vous voulez mais
ça ne veut pas dire qu en martinique
il n'y avait pas d'aidé et grève
extrêmement dure 180 mothern a bien
fusiller tout autour en personne le jeu
le parvis de l'église une amélioration
de migration équipe a été poursuivi
vettel au 20 juillet se disent qu'un de
ses 300 ans martini dans le milieu rural
c'est qu'il y avait aussi des grèves et
des grèves extrêmement dur parce qu'en
réalité il faut bien se mettre en tête 7
la chose suivante essais et c'est ça le
comte rios de mai 68
s'il n'y a pas de mouvement populaire
c'était le raisonnement à l'époque on
n'obtient rien et c'est vrai que mai 68
ap en demi d'abord d'augmenter
considérablement des salaires au mont
considérablement étant relativement
inattendue mais et est donc avec les
percussions mais est aussi il fallait
dans le milieu rural se battre pour ne
serait ce que pour être respecté et
j'ajouterai une dernière chose
nous sommes aujourd'hui confrontés à une
grave crise de santé publique avec
notamment l'état de notre centre
hospitalier universitaire avec le
problème du chlordécone et avec le même
des sargasses mais il faut bien se dire
qu'à l'époque les ouvriers agricoles par
exemple ils étaient dix semaines
le clown déconne sans masque et il
c'était une des revendications c'est
comme ça qu'est née d'ailleurs dans la
liaison qui avait entravé certains
groupes nationalistes et déduire c'est
comme ça qu'est né le fameux l'union des
travailleurs de la banane et matt de
martinique et qui étaient ces
revendications là c'était ses
revendications là donc c'est
effectivement très dur et avec aussi une
dépression extrêmement dur
allez on va inclure la nuit vous êtes
revenu en martinique à en quelle année
puisque en mai 68 vous étiez donc
j'allais infirmière vous apprêtiez à
entrer dans le métier de l'infirmière
vous êtes resté longtemps travaillé en
france ah oui je fais ma carrière tout
là bas
oui d'accord et quand vous êtes revenu
vous avez trouvé évidemment une société
complètement différent la première fois
que j'ai retenu c'est après sept ans est
ce que ça a coûté cher et vous aviez
trouvé une société qui avait beaucoup
évolué et évoluent et déjà pour les
allocations familiales je savais que
veut que ça se rapprochait ouais il va
était bien pareil et notamment du point
de vue des avancées féministes après 68
cents on a dû se battre beaucoup quand
même parce que les lois qui étaient les
allocations familiales pour qu'elle ait
le même taux on a attendu quarante ans
on les a eus on s'est battu depuis 1970
s'est passé en 1996 parce qu'il y avait
toujours une petit truc
et c'était tout comme ça la prime de
rentrée scolaire on l'a eu dix ans après
et c'était toujours des combats et les
combats des femmes à ce moment là parce
que évidemment ça évolue c'était sur le
ctg société c'est à dire on se battait
pour avoir les mêmes droits qu'en france
pour avoir les mêmes droits et c'est
devenu un peu plus après avec les
violences faites aux femmes ce terrain
pour confirmer ce que dise madame et bio
n'oublions pas que les allocations
familiales n'était pas versée
totalement aux parents c'est ça c'est ça
devient vais le tient je veux qu'on
prenait la moitié des allocations
familiales et on les mettrait dans une
sorte de deux caisses qui ont tout
simplement parce qu'on considérait ses
parents comme des gens irresponsables -
espace avait pas payé la cantine qui
vous pouvait pas mélanger
et non vous voyez donc fiable et je veux
souligner ça il ya eu donc des
répercussions de mai 68 sur évidemment
le social martiniquais mais il y avait
aussi des problématiques très spécifique
très spécifique parce que nous étions un
pays soi-disant mais je me reprendrai
une crise du point de vue donc très bien
départementale mais du point de vue des
moeurs
dd du fonctionnement c'est pas moi de la
cellule familiale des rapports peut-être
dans le travail est ce que tout ça il ya
eu des évolutions
est ce que l'esprit soixante huitard en
quelque sorte avec qu'on le disait ce
souci de sortir de la sclérose qui est
pas trop d'autoritarisme que enfin vous
voyez ce que je veux dire bon voilà est
ce que on est passé à une nouvelle
société quoi je vais vous faire unique
alliant un impact je vais vous faire une
réponse qui écrit dépenses globales
nous sommes une société distincte
6il ondes mais passe aux on n'a pas ça
c'est vrai à l'âme
nous sommes une seule chose les le
discret donc donne donc tout ce qui va
se passer
il y aura justement des choses
spécifiques et ceo le disais il se
battait pour que les banques soient
reconnus justement ce caractère
spécifique de nos sociétés et donc c'est
pas d'autres les martiniquais n'ont pas
pris tout dans une globalité
ça voulait dire a dit que bien entendu
une évolution est ce que madame aimions
d'ailleurs soulignait il ya une
évolution notamment une certaine liberté
par rapport à ce qui était interdit
auparavant mais ça a été aussi une
bataille spécifique au sein de la
société martiniquaise très bien on
termine je voudrais juste vous donner
j'ai vu ça quelque part dans dans un
texte qui parle justement des années
50-60 notamment en martinique en avril
69 les rg remarques de la défaite du
général de gaulle au référendum a
surpris des martiniquais qui eux avaient
voté alors massivement oui à 87% donc un
an après mai 68 voilà et l'opinion à ce
moment-là pas tout l'opinion pas toute
la population mais l'opinion majoritaire
pour en quelque sorte a peur d'un des
serments
des liens avec la france et donc c'est
un peu ce qui agite aussi quelque part
des parties d'assurer ce sera conclu que
c'est la droite qui est donc converti
qui est donc prépondérante en matière
d'éthique
ce sont eux qui ont les communes ils
sont majorité au conseil général et donc
et d'autres écoutent à propagande si
vous voulez assimilationniste et
singulièrement départementaliste donc
elle et elle est puissante
les médias sont du côté de la droite
à ce moment là et donc nous le combat
n'est que plus dure voilà allez leur
joie ils étaient juste pour dire que le
jeu du gal de gaulle en algérie aux
événements de 68
les algériens ne comprenait pas comment
les français pouvaient s'attaquer au
général de gaulle voilà des gens qui se
sont qui ont fait la guerre pendant dix
ans qui ont eu des dd perthus incroyable
et qui vous disais au bout de ses 10 ans
c'est le général de gaulle qui nous a
donné l'indépendance
c'est terrible c'est terrible dirigeants
et on n'était peut-être pas très loin de
cet état d'esprit aussi ils sont en
marge du camp quelque sorte que c'est la
colonisation ce qui qui qui forment
cette rue en 1800 gamin cucq les
premières élections chercheurs et élus
mais quelques mois après c'est le béké
qui a été merci l'acier propriétaires
s'ils avaient tous d'avoir participé à
ce face à la première réalisée par
rodrigue calixte merci vais très bien
merci daniel milliard merci andré
lucrèce et merci à vous armand nicolas
merci bonbons dimanche à à vous tous